Heidi's not the only one going all out
for Halloween treat why are you dressed
like that because it's my costume
oh yeah dudes go to the costume stores
they make me look stupid Kevin Hart
channeled 1996 Dwayne Johnson for his
costume slash Jumanji the next level
trailer announcement celebs have been
celebrating Halloween all week and we're
handing out awards for our faves
Jennifer Garner wins our funny / sexy
award why would you dress like a flirty
nurse when you could be a mailbox
and we award the definitely not Disney
approved trophy to Kylie Jenner for her
take on area complemented with a
bedazzled flounder purse but who wore it
better Kim to the look in 2012 our next
award best costume takedown ghost
according Cox who commented on Sarah
Foster's friends themed costume Rachel
and Phoebe you who the hell are you
but ariana grande wins Halloween with
this look kinda felt like the twilight
zone over at live with Kelly and Ryan
their Halloween spectacular was all
about viral moments I feel like the
viral moment could be your dance moves
oh are we a virus oh you mean he is um
he's a cowboy kids he let the music
piece it I let it inspire and that's
what music should do it should inspire
America it took three months to prep the
show Kelly had 11 costumes Ryan had 8
including morphing into the Addams
Family in yeah that's Kelly's hubby Mark
Consuelos alt Gomez
meanwhile Whitney Williams was
ringmaster of her own circus this
morning and it was dance fever for both
the Today Show and GMA GMA's genders day
in today's Savannah Guthrie both even
channels Olivia newton-john
for their Halloween costume
[Music]